hi my name is herb Chang this is joint
work in person she from Baylor
University and she in fan so today I'm
talking about fungal infections family
infections in fact more than 1 billion
people a year and kills more than 1.5
million people a year worldwide since
the braceland healthcare problem this is
a joint project of baking Union Medical
College Hospital very hung University
Pfizer and Mike cell research what want
to do is provide a tour in the cloud
that allow doctors to help to make a
diagnosis on the type of fungal
measuring so we're using a deep neural
network called by linear CN n to help to
make those ha spacing with the Pamir CN
we increase the accuracy from original
78 percent to 90 percent so we are
trying to classify among five different
classes of fungal infections and so
here's the computer matrix you can see
that we are enhancing the classification
accuracy as you get more data over
finding
so this is a typical image my baby
uploaded to the system to generate a
conservation result what we're doing is
also providing the activation map that's
used by the deep neural net to make the
determination so this is very important
because there's a new research palpable
a I want to give doctors a way to sort
of visualize how the deep neural Nets
making a decision this is important so
that doctor can see for the people next
looking at the same features that they
were looking at for example for this
string of the fungal infection the the
color and the contrast at the bulb area
is very important so can they even see
that it's the same feature being used by
the deep neural net so this is another
type of fungal infection so you can see
that the system's also extracting all
the features that the doctor will be
looking at so after we have clean up
this classification algorithm we can
provide the service in Macau that's
reachable to a mobile phone and with
this move open where you can upload
information such as the image then you
see under the microscope plus metadata
such as the Culture Media that's used to
grow the the sample plus the conditions
such as temperature and then the system
will provide suggest that reference
material to look happy
we hoped would make a better decision on
what type of fungal infection it is and
also the system allowed the doctor to
provide metadata such as additional
information about the patient and also
the treatment and anything for that so
when its system provide the reference
material he also provides a gallery so
unlike currently where the doctor only
have a reference book maybe with two or
three images that they can use to look
at a computer type of a fungal infection
now they have a constantly enhanced and
enlarging they have said that they can
look at plus additional information such
as doctors who provided the same hope so
they can actually comes out with other
doctors so believe that over time all
professionals will use tools such as
these enhance by AI to enhance their
work so that they can make it bigger to
make better decisions over time thank
you very much